[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
abend an diesem ostermontag die
feiertage haben die innenpolitische
debatte über waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine gedämpft zu ende ist sie nicht
die rufe aus der ukraine an die
westlichen partner schnell mit schweren
waffen zu helfen sind laut und dringlich
inzwischen sieht kiew anzeichen dafür
dass die erwartete offensive im osten
des landes beginnen
gleichzeitig verstärkt russland seine
luftangriffe auch wieder auf ziele im
westen heute morgen traf ist lemberg
ulrike rödl beginnt damit ihren bericht
die raketenangriffe kamen am morgen fünf
seien es insgesamt gewesen sein eine
druckwelle zerstört die fensterscheiben
einer unterkunft hier hatten menschen
schutz gesucht die aus anderen regionen
der ukraine geflohen waren auch eine
autowerkstatt wurde zerstört und teile
der bahnstrecke
etwas traf das nachbarhaus dann
zerbrachen die scheiben wir hatten angst
und wussten nicht was wir tun sollten
also haben wir angefangen zu bieten
der bürgermeister von lemberg spricht
von mindestens sechs toten darunter auch
ein kind
wir wenden uns an die ganze welt damit
jeder es versteht wenn wir den feind
nicht stoppen und aus unserem land
vertreiben dann wird er immer
weitermachen
dazu passt dass das russische
verteidigungsministerium heute diese
bilder präsentiert raketenangriffe auf
mehrere städte man sei so ein sprecher
erfolgreich gewesen ziel waren die
regionen noch faxe briefe und j
die russischen luftabwehrsysteme haben
heute insgesamt sechs ukrainische
kampfflugzeuge abgeschossen außerdem elf
ukrainische drohnen
dass es bei den russischen angriffen
viele tote gibt viele zivile opfer davon
kein wort so wie in mario pohl
auf den straßen leichen die häuser in
schutt und asche gebombt noch immer
warten die menschen darauf aus der stadt
zu kommen bislang ohne erfolg auch heute
wieder
ähnliche bilder auch aus kharkiv hier
wurden nach ukrainischen angaben in den
letzten tagen mindestens 18 menschen
getötet und über 100 verletzt
evakuiert wohin sie greifen mittlerweile
die ganze ukraine an sie haben heute
lemberg angegriffen und mehr pro überall
schlagen sie zu
[Musik]
jetzt offenbar auch vermehrt im osten
etwa 50 kilometer von grammatik entfernt
hier sollen russische truppen ihre
offensive begonnen haben der krieg in
der ukraine er dauert nun schon 54 tage
ja dominique weltmeister ist für uns in
kiew dominik es gibt eben heute abend
diese meldungen dass die offensive der
russischen armee begonnen habe oder
haben könnte was können sie uns dazu
sagen
ja zumindest mal verdichten sich die
hinweise dass diese offensive in der ost
ukraine begonnen hat der ukrainische
generalstab otto abend zitat anzeichen
der des beginns der offensive quasi
genannt das ist sozusagen für uns dass
das das hätte ihn heta hinweis darauf
dass ist in dieser nacht los geht es
gibt auch meldungen aus hacke von donuts
von vorstößen der russischen truppen und
das pasta mit zusammen dass auch der
ukrainische generalstab gesagt hat dass
die vorbereitung der russischen truppen
beendet sein
dass also die situation im osten der
westen der ukraine schien bisher
vergleichsweise sicher was bedeuten die
luftangriffe auf lemberg die wir gerade
gesehen haben auf lemberg zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt
ja ich glaube dass die russische armee
an dieser stelle einfach druck machen
will auf die ukraine man hat mit diesen
angriffen den ganzen land noch einmal
gezeigt so was man fähig ist und es
wurden ja auch in lemberg
eisenbahnlinien bombardiert die sind
nötig für waffen aus dem westen zu
transportieren lemberg im westen ist ja
die stadt wo auch die ganzen waffen noch
durch durch müssen und deswegen ist es
verständlich dass die russische armee an
dieser stelle auch zuge dieser offensive
hier diese diese wichtige infrastruktur
bombardiert
dankeschön für heute abend dominik
löschmeister und wir bleiben bei dominik
sein bericht zeigt uns jetzt einen
freiwilligen helfer aus deutschland der
menschen aus dem osten der ukraine
herausholt das ist eine gefährliche
aufgabe nicht selten sind autos busse
flüchtende in den letzten wochen gezielt
beschossen worden für die menschen die
gehen und damit lange gewartet haben ist
es die vielleicht letzte chance ein
alter linienbus als lebensretter in kiel
verlagen sie hilfsgüter kochen essen für
die menschen die sie raus bringen wollen
aus der umkämpften ost ukraine ralf
kubon kommt aus deutschland er ist einer
der gründer der hilfsorganisation eines
ihr ziel menschen den krisengebieten in
sicherheit bringen geplant ist die
evakuierung eines dorfs wir haben
kontakt man da vor ort
dass es sehr nah an der kampfzone und
man rechnet damit dass die kampfzone
auch diesen ort erreichen wird
530 kilometer geht es richtung ost
ukraine auch eine kurze panne hält sie
nicht auf zwölf stunden später erreichen
silos super es muss jetzt schnell gehen
hilfsgüter auslagen jederzeit könnte es
beschuss geben die russischen truppen
sind nicht weit
wir gehen ja verlässt nur schweren
herzens ihren heimatort ihre eltern
wollen bleiben
wir gehen weil die kinder leiden und
weinen kampfflugzeuge fliegen es gibt
explosionen es ist einfach hoffnungslos
ich mache mir sorgen um meine eltern es
heißt abschied nehmen von den männern
die noch im ort sind viele frauen sind
aber mit ihren kindern bereits alleine
unsere partner bei der ukrainischen
armee
ich hatte meine zweifel weil ich meinen
mann der in der territorialverteidigung
ist nicht zurücklassen wollte ich mache
mir natürlich sorgen um ihr
mitnehmen können sie nur einen kleinen
koffer ein paar persönliche dinge die
menschen hier haben eine traumatische
zeit hinter sich
meine kinder und enkelkinder sind
bereits geflohen sie sind jetzt den
pulheim bei köln ich war allein hier ich
bin schon lehrerin hier kann ich keine
kinder mehr unterrichten
ich habe mich entschieden zu gehen die
hälfte ist geschafft für ralf über den
deutschen helfer gleich geht es los dass
er aus dem alter kommt die flut
katastrophe erlebte einer seiner
beweggründe hier zu helfen wenn man das
gefühl kennen da von der einen auf die
andere nacht alles zu verlieren dann
glaube ich bekomme man einen ganz guten
impuls dazu anderen menschen helfen
er bringt die menschen raus aus der ost
ukraine
eine lange fahrt morgen wollen sie in
polen seien
fast fünf millionen menschen haben die
ukraine inzwischen verlassen mehr als
die hälfte davon sind nach polen
geflogen um sich in sicherheit zu
bringen auch um nicht allzu weit weg zu
sein von der heimat der polnische
grenzschutz berichtet heute dass
inzwischen und tag mehr flüchtlinge in
die ukraine zurück kehren als nach polen
einreisen ein gewaltiges risiko auch
wenn gebiete als zurückerobert gelten
das
bundesinnenministerium gab die zahl der
nach deutschland geflüchteten heute mit
gut
357.000 an um sie kümmern sich überall
im land ehrenamtliche nachbarschaft
netzwerke freundeskreise solidarität ins
da und ohne sie ginge es gar nicht aber
viele helferinnen und helfer kommen nach
wochen der unterstützung inzwischen an
ihre grenzen wenn regen berichtet aus
hamburg helena und jens volk sind am
limit seit die ersten schutz suchen denn
aus der ukraine in hamburg ankamen
organisieren die beiden was staatliche
stellen wie hier in hamburg bis heute
nicht schaffen sie verteilen flüchtlinge
direkt auf gastfamilien und sie bleiben
in kontakt denn immer häufiger passt es
nicht es gibt natürlich auch dass
familien die einfach nicht
zusammenpassen und
konfrontiert man natürlich also und da
versuchen wir auch die beiden fällen
klarzumachen entfernt da macht er das
oder erträgt diese reibereien und die
dauerhafte doppelbelastung mit beruf und
privater hilfe
zehrt an nerven und kostet kraft der
gemeinsame urlaubstag an der ostsee ist
eine persönliche ruheoase ein kurzer
moment in dem die bilder aus lenas
heimat aber trotzdem präsent sind zwei
meiner begriff zusammengebrochen
straße und haben geweint und sie unsere
auch eine freiwillige wollen sie auch
hat jetzt angerufen und gesagt komm her
holzes oft hierher aus der zusammenbruch
war hier vor der zentralen erstaufnahme
in hamburg zurzeit ist es dort ruhig
schutzsuchende aus der ukraine kommen
weniger an die freiwilligen helfer wie
claudia kraemer sind trotzdem geblieben
die stadt beschränkt sich derzeit auf
das nötigste man macht sich nicht
abhängig von irgendwelchen behörden und
auflagen man macht es so wie man es
möchte dem herzen entsprechend also ich
möchte einfach was machen ich kann nicht
nichts tun helfer und dolmetscher sind
rar mischa ist elf seine eltern sind vor
langer zeit aus russland gekommen und
verabscheuen putins krieg so oft er kann
ist micha da um zu helfen und um zu
übersetzen
micha überbringt die gute nachricht eine
der helferinnen bringt die ukrainische
familie zum hauptbahnhof
mischa der harry potter aus
hamburg-rahlstedt zaubert mit wörtern
die stadt entzaubert mit solchen
flugblättern auf deutsch
einen kurzen magischen moment hat auch
helen nachfolgt der ausflug an die
ostsee ist für sie eine reise in die
vergangenheit ihre familie kam über das
spätaussiedler abkommen nach deutschland
als jetzt und anderen gedanken auch ein
gewinn so ein bisschen in mich hinein
meister und
wie nötig diese pausen für die
freiwilligen helfer sind haben sie schon
gemerkt eine mitorganisatorin musste ins
krankenhaus die emotionale belastung war
einfach zu groß
ja und lässt sich nicht einfach
abstellen wir machen hier nun weiter mit
nachrichten und gundula gause
der ukraine krieg war das beherrschende
thema der ostermärsche an denen sich
bundesweit tausende beteiligt haben auch
heute gab es in rund 30 städten
friedensdemonstrationen darunter am
luftwaffenstützpunkt büchel in der eifel
friedensaktivisten vermuten dort die
letzten noch in deutschland
stationierten atomwaffen zentrale
forderung aller ostermärsche ein
waffenstillstand in der ukraine und das
ende des russischen angriffskrieges
gesundheitsminister lauterbach hat mit
seiner warnung vor einer möglichen so
genannten killer variante des corona
virus kritik ausgelöst der virologe
schmidt-chanasit sagte der bild zeitung
die sei unwissenschaftlich und
verunsichere laut whu sei eine killer
variante ein unwahrscheinliches szenario
auch der virologe streik erklärte man
könne die entwicklung von varianten
nicht vorhersagen
im zuge des corona ausbruchs in shanghai
haben die behörden der chinesischen
millionenmetropole die ersten todesfälle
gemeldet es soll sich um drei ältere vor
erkrankte handeln die nicht geimpft
gewesen sein täglich gibt es derzeit in
china mehr als 20.000 neuinfektionen
fast alle in shanghai die hafenstadt ist
seit ende märz weitgehend im lockdown
millionen menschen dürfen ihre wohnungen
nicht verlassen
in schweden ist es in mehreren städten
bei protesten gegen kundgebungen einer
rechtsextremen partei zu schweren
ausschreitungen gekommen auslöser waren
koranverbrennungen eines rechtsextremen
politikers wie hier in northampton
zündeten randalierer fahrzeuge an und
beschädigten gebäude 15
gegendemonstranten und 26 polizisten
wurden verletzt
heute vor 75 jahren sprengte die
britische airforce alle militäranlagen
der wehrmacht auf helgoland mit einem
gottesdienst wurde auf helgoland der
operation bigbank von
1947 gedacht bei dem großen knall
detonierten 6700 tonnen munition
alle ehemaligen nazi anlagen auf der
insel wurden zerstört die bis dahin
größte sprengung weltweit veränderte die
oberfläche der felseninsel nachhaltig
fehle noch die wetteraussichten die
überwiegend frühlingshaft bleiben nur im
südosten überwiegen die wolken in der
lausitz in nieder und oberbayern kann es
schauer geben sonst bleibt es trocken
bei viel sonne in der osthälfte 7 bis 14
in der westhälfte 14 bis 20 grad ab
mittwoch mehr wolken im norden und osten
am freitag kann es am alpenrand regnen
10 bis 21 grad
soweit unser blick auf den ostermontag
um 23 50 gibt es hier die schnelle
nachrichtenüberblick in einer heute
express so ist es und bis morgen
[Musik]